[Musica]
benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio di wired
confavi gente si è sentita oggi ragazzi
faremo un gioco wire un po più
movimentato di cose da altra volta che
non so se conosce tipo counter strike è
che un gioco tipo di stampa farmi si
difende è che a youtube non piacciono
quelle parole è un gioco pam pam pam
però fatto il guar adesso mettiamo il
quale vediamo come allora oggi signor
parigi e vi insegna una cosa molto
family friendly questo che per non
confondere di tutti lo chiameremo bang
bang va usato con questo che è sempre
perché ho fatto di più lo chiameremo
temperino il temperino va nel bang bang
e va tirata dibatti nato il righello una
volta che tira il righello tirato il
tiranno e rigato afferri la il bang bang
davanti e poi bang bang
ecco non è vero non ci credo
ha funzionato pro poteva fare ben meglio
su me stesso
vorrei riuscire a fare una partita di
bang bang quindi apriamo il menu o
scaricato una mappa carina select
difficoltà mettiamo easy perché sennò
sono nella cassetta
anzi facciamo nonna era troppo easy
action ayane idrica a vedere
devi di caricare tu devi fare tutto
esattamente come se fosse la bang bang
vera stesso prova a fare una cosa però
sono in uk tapi devo fare come una cosa
incredibile non so se mi ammazzerò poi
ci ha capito
mai però noi non ce ne forniscono io ci
devo a rosetta sono nella casa quella
prima dove c'era la scaletta sino a sono
morto aspetta ci devo provare dove ecco
noi non c'è più secchi non posso rifarlo
volevo fare una cosa incredibile
va bene arti dato non è fatto
veramente male questo nuketown non so
perché c'è una texture e non ha senso
perchè il bayern potrebbe reggere e fate
una yurta fatta tipo su human full flat
perfetto allora percorrere devo togliere
la mano dall'ara non ci credo ti prego
no ti prego sono sono friendly sono
friendly nomi non fare niente non fare
andiamo entriamo in macchina questi cosa
stanno facendo
volevo dire entrare in casa ho detto si
entra in macchina questi cosa fanno di
schifoso come si tira fuori il quello
per affettare le cose eccolo però non ha
idea se non sarà facile
non voglio farlo non hai idea possa che
lanciarlo sì ma non così li ma non ho
fatto un film che se prendiamo qualche
nome landauer la gente veramente per
modifiche sul sacco
sono bravissimo la punta del bang bang
afferrata con l'altra mano esattamente
così e la fine che ha fatto è giusta ma
quello mio compagno mio compagno
sparando mio compagno può scusami ma sai
che forse io finora non sbaglio ho
attaccato sempre i miei compagni non
dovevo il prefetto
questo l 1 0 14 madonna anni devo ricard
ma non è vero ma non ama veramente dio
infilare uno per uno
aiuto non mi abituerò mai a questa cosa
ciao ciao che soccorreva veramente
storto c'è chi è impegnato per fare aver
distorto su vari tipi wanted
sì però non l'ho preso tieni è
difficilissimo cirene volere libera una
mira incredibile cioè è difficile come
che era un coltello vero è veramente
difficile
tieni zio allah è grande ma è una
granata finta 1234 gay no scherzavo se
la prima l'aiuto di 90 vesto male quanto
sanno trovare un p 92 così
il mio sogno è avere mira c'è una mappa
online dai cannoni my friends che
windows mac ora i am news week end
insomma beirut i like i love the weapon
murdoch the pagine magari non mi sta
sentendo nessuno prova boe giorno
bravo cita un riscatto morte io non sono
fesso no dopo ci sono però incredibile
la mia prima kill non ho mai giocato sta
roba attenzione round one with good job
guys giorgio vaime da chi laimburg di
schemi no thank you so much for the
support 2 a guys thank you
hai tu che vuoi con idee pavimento no no
id smaila con mettendo che certe o thank
you thank you from the block diverso più
alla gruber sono yacht l'hype and
protection of you want conai protective
because you now but when you're not my
friends with my brother brier friends
aiuto perché il nuova patch out sono
fortissimo accetta però non so come si
ricarica avete un tizzone già molti
prodotti è stato figo guys hai hai hai
made to kill se hai un fortissimo no
trust mi ha in sé per periodi schema m
insomma skills and wood che purtroppo mi
sono qualche ai bonus di coltello ma
anche l aido dermon e guy drop mi sono
film don't worry nyteknik gun annoiano
camp nou proprio hi i'm into you to like
clint eastwood rino like
very fast and new way let's go i'm ready
to every thing guys place montecchio des
adesso mio best leather son people ir e
primaria dai tribal so many people so
many people in the park mentor news
qualcuno ha detto antonio antonio
wordpress
ok now have a good gang di cose di for
guys this time vecchi le prime thanasis
sarà 7 di corsa però ok ai modelli al
reddito killer sono state sani
sono tantissimo aveva fatto da doc chi
ha fatto la doppia guys and killed two
people in da pac man size wood thank you
ok al meglio bisnonno ai fini che deve
fare una partners ha però fatto tra chi
sono fortissimo non round sono veramente
dei filmati come si chiama the guys
thank you saved di frey tra i pali geri
però si trovi incredibile quello del
round di provarlo incredibile la in 3d
grazie veramente incredibile leggo
perché questo dove dove passano capito
sognavo ai camper viro ma non aver mai a
year it com cav h non un bel catalogo
che non avevo il caricatore che pirla
l'avo lasciato per terra gli avevo la
bomba tra l'altro sensori guys ai forgot
burqa il velo the weapon le bombe is not
guarise ma anche se sono passati la
bomba avrebbe liceo
ok nava i try to kill lancio the knife
poi tre i falchi someone ma proprio
aspetta che questo è un problema su
qualche caso di no porca vacca ai tweet
now e quindi thank you guys ai need to
quit ansur ribatte thank you for the
the farm aid smartphone insomma thank
you thank you for the match
bye bye bye bye bye arriva
vabbè basta dies ero qua e l'intero
convinto di essere la prima che va bè
ragazzi adesso gioco incredibile questo
gioco incredibile incredibile veramente
passano le giornate qua
ragazzi questa è la pavlov un gioco di
bang bang e win win
[Musica]
superati gli sia piaciuto cosa che mi
piace quando mi piace cavalli sono
alcuni dei dati schizzare senso che si
chiede ci vediamo allora prossimo bang
bang da ragazzi
[Musica]